yeah I remember here's a fun story well
I when I open for Louie years ago he
would always be like man I would kill
beware you are like just running around
Brooklyn earning laughs cuz he gets a
lot of laughs based on being Louie you
know so he's like I would kill to get
that genuine response again just to know
if it's actually funny killed me where
you are cut to two years later he gets
popped and I text him I was like hey
welcome back to my level and he never
wrote back so I think he was a the guy
went too far there but it was still raw
I should have given it in like a month
[Music]
in the middle of couch now we're like on
late-night oh yeah panel new late-night
right now there we go you made it to
panel congratulation yeah feels like I
banged you it we're having like an
interview after now what do we do now
can we tell everybody do we keep it a
secret
well I felt like that when we were doing
I was like well what food do you want
and then I was like I'm here I parked
what room like it was a whole like set
up here yeah like a one-night stand
oh yeah Wow look at that
we have our own water now since we last
did this - Wow hot breath I've had that
in the morning yeah that's all for you
man oh thanks jeez you got your own
water you got your own office now that's
great I don't even know where to begin
just because I'm excited to get you back
on here after two years and two years
it's been almost two years to the date
yeah and I haven't progressed you
haven't still in the same hotel room
it's an any worse hotels out on the road
this is the W Midtown Atlanta you're
watching a work in the Laughing Skull
all weekend oh yeah so let's welcome
them a hot breath averse welcome to this
hot breath assaut today's guest really
needs no introduction the last time he
was on here back in hot
the sowed number 84 we talked all about
just his rough start where he was a
janitor sleeping on trains getting
robbed all in his pursuit of comedy and
now we're going to interview him about
his recent successes and this is guy
right here is just the comedian who's
just focused on being funny not worrying
about what other people are thinking
besides the voices in your head sure
sure which is always just doing the work
I think is a big message of this episode
in this comedian so a prime example of
what you can get out of just focusing on
being funny consistently so that being
said well said here here mark Normand
welcome to the hot breath averse good to
be here in my hotel room thanks for
coming up and you brought he brought
snacks
so I brought snacks give a big thanks
for the snacks underrated yes a long way
people I brought you some flowers or
whatever it and snacks yeah we just want
to eat that's what a thing I made with
this podcast before we had our own water
it was I would just bring people like
water that I printed printed labels on
like myself just because like you just
want to add a little something for the
guests make them remember you oh yeah
but I don't even know what you ate
you're kind of like you're kind of like
low-key in shape now wow like and then
you're like oh he's like like working
out like what's the what's going on here
well I cut back on the sauce it was a
real booze bag and then I was always
just rotten fruit you know I was just do
II so I said I'll go to the gym once a
week and that's it you just go once you
go once a week I used to box I got
really into boxing for a while with my
trainer guy fell off we'll get to that
later but and I was like I don't want to
meet a new guy and all that so I just
gave up on the boxing thing but now I
just do little dumb tricks I you know
when you're on the subway I just lift my
feet off the ground it's like a little
OCD thing that gets the ABS going
there's always time to do I do weird
squats in the morning I do what I call
bed jumps you know I'm in a hotel room
so often that I'll just jump from the
floor to the bed 30 times which doesn't
sound that crazy but it really gets the
the core burnin
hmm he's gonna get those knees up look
give it a whirl if you ever get feeling
chunky and what about one of the squats
what are the squats you did oh well I
have weirds I have weird
I have zero thigh I have no thigh meat
it's just just femur and is that femur
yeah it's just femur and so I just go up
and down you know like and I do that 50
times and that burns and you squeeze
your butt on the way up I've seen all
these thing I saw this on YouTube and I
just stole it but I'm in a hotel room so
much and I have to like I have to do
like prison workout kind of [ __ ] mm-hmm
yeah you act like you're not doing
anything and then you just rattled off
like four things I guess you're right
but those only take like three minutes
each so I made it out I'm done in half
an hour
you do that you said once a week but is
it I do that every day and that gym I go
once a week oh okay so you're doing
something I'm doing so I just feel some
guilt about the food I eat I still drink
a lot of whiskey and bourbon so I got to
do something and you know I'm watching
my friends like a friends who were
hitting their fort their 40s and they're
they're slowly dying yeah so I'm scared
of that I'm 35 now so I got to get
cooking yeah that's why I'm 31 and like
I'm at the tipping point where it's like
all right you can't just get away with
anything or it starts to kind of yeah
karma will hit you it hits you [ __ ]
like I used to just drink a hundred
beers not a hundred but I just drink a
bunch of beers all night I would just
drink and now I'm like oh that beer is
this many calorie it's like I hate that
guy but you got to worry but have you
seen an uptick in your professional
success as your health has I think so
yeah I've noticed that yeah look at like
John Mulaney Dan Soder Joe list all
these guys got sober and just took off
yeah
so I I like booze too much to quit so
I've just said all right I'm just gonna
tamp it down a little bit and not just
black out four nights a week but let's
look at drunk
I just want blackout so that so I have
my little what do you call it
compromises okay you'll still drink but
you have the self-control tonight yeah I
mean I had three whiskey's last night
Thursday
lift it up and then you just brought
chicken fingers I'm eating that so you
know I'm still living goddamn it but I
know I feel like so many people in this
business
comedy is fun it's so much fun this
there's booze and there's laughs and
there's you know friends everybody's
hanging out in green room and the free
meal and the horrible racist jokes it's
a good time but like no one's having fun
now no one everybody's sober everybody's
starting families and all that and all
that's great and I get it but I feel
like it's not as fun as it used to be
comedy well it used to be I'm talking I
love comedy I still love doing stand-up
but I used to be blowing rails and
groupies and you know this and that and
now it's comedies very like I don't know
it's very it's it's tamer it's like a
professional it's professional it's like
a workplace well because before you
didn't have to do the social media [ __ ]
guzzling [ __ ] all day with the I got my
story
here's the ticket link here's me on a
tour I'm fat I'm gay
here we go all day long branding
branding you know you'd have to do that
before before you just wrote jokes told
jokes party and now it's like you know I
gotta get on Facebook got a promote
gotta tag this gotta do things with
friends got to start a podcast it's so
much and I have a web series you know
it's a lot it's a job it's a job job
mark I know it sucks you should not be a
job well look at the impact comedy is
having now as well yeah that's true
it's booming now booming so you gotta
give some sort of credit there you're
right everything everything has a given
a take you know like comedies bigger
than it's ever been but it's also kind
of censored again a little bit and I
mean you can still do what you want but
uh you know it's weird now the thing
that kills me is I don't mind the people
getting offended and all that they're
allowed to be offended but to me it's
the other comics coming after comics
that's that really stung yeah when you
hit were you tomorrow Louis CK's
incident Wow see that's a whole
different that's a whole nother bag of
hammers but like I'm just saying like a
comic says this and then another comic
like hey that's inappropriate what are
you doing come on yeah I'm into the
belief that like comedy is a language
they're like comedians can speak yeah
and like we just have a rapport that
I feel like outside of comedy people
just don't have a context for right
anytime a comedian says something I'm
not like oh how dare you I'm like other
comedian just like ya talk the language
yeah I mean how many comics have said
horrible things about like men or
whatever and then she comes off stage
and you're like hey what's up cuz you're
in the green room now you're back to
reality this role these are all jokes
but I have a theory and sorry so tell me
I'm talking too much this is your show
Murphy I'm gay so that's your that's
your ultimate out you always just say
I'm gay yeah yeah which is funny because
whatever gay guys get you know gay guys
you always hear about I'm getting beat
up for being gay I've always gotten out
of fights by saying I'm gay you know
like hey did you just touch my
girlfriend's ass I'm like I'm gay and
they're like oh alright alright I
thought I was gonna beat your ass for a
minute so uh your theory what was my
point we were talking about comedians
offending and you had a theory oh I got
it back alright thank you so I think
come I think everything is so phony now
like the news everything is fake I'm
gonna you know what every quote every
platitude big is beautiful but then you
still go to the gym so you're like which
one is it you know so everything is all
just like feelings base and got to be
nice and all that so I think comedy the
whole point of comedy the whole funny
thing about it is it's true you know
it's funny cuz it's true or that's it's
so relatable I feel the same way
so comedies like the last place you can
tell the truth you can't tell the truth
on the news now the news is gone the
news is journalism is horrific
so like now they're gonna come after it
cuz they're like damn it we've kind of
these people over like hey that we've
we've stifled everything we've we've
stopped everything out true why's the
comedy they're still doing it so I think
people are a going towards it which is
why it's so popular and be coming after
it angrily because it's true it's a lot
of it's true
yeah to see a like a solution or resolve
I think I think you just got to keep
doing it cuz we used to go oh my god I'm
sorry let me retract my statement now
just just go just don't apologize keep
going and I'm not I'm not saying say
horrible things you know if you're some
alright weirdo get out of here you know
if you're some way guy was just like why
can't I say the n-word you're like all
right you you're bad
but like if you're just being funny and
it's a good point
that's comedy get over it
I think the cue point there is funny yes
yes funny
yes exactly and that goes on all fronts
if you're gonna if you're gonna [ __ ] on
Trump go nuts but it's gotta be funny
don't just go he sucks and everybody
collapsed that's not rape is bad
racism is evil yeah yeah no [ __ ] that's
easy that's agreeance
that's not stand up that's not comedy
it's spoken word well good work it's
just poetry if there aren't laughs
that's what I don't care as long as it's
long as it gets a laugh yeah kudos for
finding that laugh here here agreed
even if it's not the most horrible dead
baby school shooting pedophilia AIDS
rape cancer if it's funny it's funny
because you always hear all you can't do
rape jokes but I have a joke my act
where I get raped kills kills so it's
like Oh see you're against rape jokes
but if I get raped it's okay what about
B you said that in our our last
interview who did on here you had a
quote when you worked with louis c.k and
he said to make your jokes personal
instead of saying hangovers are like
this you go I was hungover
Wow you remember a good memory do you
remember that because that's like one of
those gyms you're like oh yeah just flip
it on to you always flip it yeah I had a
joke years ago about how JEWS gay guys
must be jealous of jews because jews
want to reproduce and procreate and
build more and gay guys can't reproduce
but they still keep coming up you know
and and i talked to him and he was like
talk about how you're not Jewish and
that'll be in the way in and once I did
that the whole joke started killing it's
a fun little nugget but yeah personal
always personalize but don't over
personalize don't over don't just go me
me me me you know jump in with you so
they go cuz otherwise they go why is he
talking about this what does he's not
Jewish what is this about huh but then
once you get into it then you can do the
bit so you're almost the filter or the
context for whatever you're trying to
yes exactly that's gold
that's good stuff that's old you're the
filter you have any other you have any
other nuggets you've picked up over the
years you can
you could share with the hot breath
averse Oh big nugget big nugget well I
have noticed now with now people are so
buzzword II like if you just say my gay
roommate they go uh-oh you're like it's
my roommate relax but just that word gay
makes people tense up just because
that's the world we're living in now
like HR is up our ass and you get fire
for saying this or you lose your sitcom
for tweeting that whatever it is so I've
noticed now that I used to say that
their [ __ ] would pucker and I would
just go oh oh sorry hold on but now if I
just lean in more they're into it so
just go in all the way you know it's as
if like a girl put her hand on your knee
and you were like and then you wanted
her to keep going but you didn't want to
say anything and then she put her hand
on your junk and you're like alright you
know what I'm saying like push a little
give it a little push but with
confidence
sure oh you're believing don't don't as
soon as they got worried you got worried
but it's like just press through that
discomfort yes yes
okay confidence Wow confidence and just
go hey these are just words we're all
gonna die one day it's a comedy club I'm
a comedian
here's more joke till it's almost like
Jeselnik Josa next great comic he says
some horrible things but he show
over-the-top evil in his act he's got
the smile and the hair and the face and
the voice and he's just like oh this is
happening and you kind of relax more
because you're like it is happening
we're in a hundred percent you know it
so it's so outlandish the the darkness
that he says that like it makes it okay
again
where's if a guy's tiptoeing around it
it's like let's guys seem shady and
weird do you find that that's how you
can get an audience on your side like
I've been I've been doing longer sets
now so I've been noticing trying to like
find that rhythm with the audience and
the first couple of minutes in a longer
set you're trying to figure him out and
all of a sudden there's that like aha
moment we're gonna just jump on your
side right is that and I saw you do this
last night as well where you were kind
of just doing your jokes it in some
laughs and all of a sudden you did a
joke and it just like broke it open does
that come with just
continuing to hit on your rhythm
continue to hit on your pattern and not
trying to let the audience to delegate
what you do does that mean I guess that
is I guess I just do the road so much of
that subconscious where you got to talk
about the city or in talk about the
local stuff for two minutes
riff on a guy in the room you got to
just show you're in the room you got to
show you know where you are a little bit
cuz it's weird when those guys come out
and go hey I was at the bank today and
you're like whoa no hello no nothing
like we're just right in there it's it's
almost like anal sex you gotta ease you
gotta ease it in you can't just jam a
fist in there you got to put the lube on
maybe a make out a candle then get in
there but uh yeah I think that's just
there's something I learned where you
just kind of gotta you gotta grab the
hand before you grab the vagina a lot of
sexual references yeah I guess so well I
mean it's basically they see you and
they have to process give them a minute
to process you can't just go right in
and go oh my wife's [ __ ] or whatever and
they're like what who how'd we get here
let them get to know you just uh
just a handshake huh but you know you
have those jokes ready and then you just
want you once you got them comfortable
and sitting and know who you are then
throw that first killer out and you're
off to the races I think I've noticed
with your your delivery is there's
there's like a certain like pausing and
there's you almost like pause before a
punch line or pause in between punch
lines like your timing within is there
some is there some voodoo you're
sprinkling in your material where you do
have these kind of brief pauses that
build the tension that make the joke
work yeah I mean I feel like a pause is
a huge advantage we have you know just I
feel like a pause is almost like a [ __ ]
huh where it accentuates the punch line
a little more I don't know just but any
kind of tension you can build and then
break is better obviously don't want to
pause for a minute but give it a one
beat and then say and I feel like that
that always helps the punch so sometimes
when you're developing material the
difference between it working or not can
be if you just take a beat and then say
it verse you just run oh yeah oh yeah
that can make a joke go from
fifty percent to a 70 percent I think
yeah always got a pauses as big it takes
confidence though I guess but if you
know the joke if you know where the
punch line is you can hang in there for
a beat mm-hmm
you know it's it's like that uh like a
guy whining up and then punching you you
know it's you can do a bunch of little
rabbit punches jab jab jab but then you
want that uppercut to really you know so
yeah I would I would always give a pause
okay pause before the punch line this is
101 here that's that's what this whole
show is oh is that what this is all
right forgotten you forgot yelling for
the show this is like comedy community
mastery yeah oh wow you're a hot breath
your weekly guide to comedy mastery gee
I don't know if a mastery I masturbated
earlier yeah yeah I use cocoa butter but
I don't know about mastery I'm just a
road hack trying to pay the mortgage no
but I mean we we learned from every
facet of it too so like we had Craig
shoemaker on here
the love dog a love master master do you
know you're I'm sure he's both yes crazy
uh you know he's a love master he had a
crazy groupie story of like there's some
there's some liquids involved it was a
lot of squirting on demand whoa he said
he had only like told it before once
he's like I'll never tell it again after
it was pretty gnarly but you you don't
brand yourself as the love master but
you I mean I really love doctor that's
what it is I never got my doctorate but
I I definitely dabbled in the ways of
the night I really got after it I mean I
was in a 12-year relationship and then I
just went ham yeah on the gash because
that was your high school sweetheart
right yes yeah yeah so after that I mean
it was weird cuz it was like right when
bumble and tinder was popping so like
that was all out there to use I had so
many resources and you know I was
working all these comedy clubs in the in
New York City and all over the country
so
like you could just land in Denver
excuse me
Oh semen and you just land in Denver and
then just start scrolling and be like oh
man look at this and then you're the guy
at the comedy clubs he already looked
cool you're like hey I'm performing here
all weekend they're like oh [ __ ] I know
he's not a serial killer he's here and
you know it's better than just being
like hey I'm a loser well you let me go
down on you you know you have a thing
where you're a comedian so it was pretty
also I used to bring me Schumer and that
was like you know ten thousand screaming
ladies and I can't bang her so I got the
run off what was the most maybe in one
night ah jeez I feel bad this is this is
gonna get me in trouble but I don't know
I had a three for a hat-trick in New
York whoa
woke up at a girl's place bang met a
girl for lunch
bang met a girl that night bang but it's
just you know those days are over now I
got a I got a hot lady of course yes but
yeah we had a we had a good run but it
just it does where it wears off you know
like after a while you're like this is a
lot of work my whole life was you know
juggling and texting and trying to be
funny with this wouldn't be charming
with that one and then put out a fire
over here and all that and it was it's
it's a lot of messaging yeah that's a
lot of work yeah just going in somewhere
then you hit do you have a system for
like did you end up having like go to
women every time you hit a certain city
yeah yeah roster yeah that was fun that
was fun and the ladies they're there
they're having a good time as well you
know this wasn't all just you know macho
[ __ ] this is like hey you're having
fun I don't [ __ ] shame I hope you don't
[ __ ] shame and let's be grownups here
and have a good time genitalia wise so
what is so Craig Craig had his story of
like this she was like a playmate or
whatever with her friend and she one
could like squirt on demand and the
other one could like queef on demand Wow
so what is a comedy duo well you know
the love-master
I guess so yeah got it so what is what
story does the love doctor have of OGS
hey love the tape well I
did a show once in Florida this is years
ago and I got an uber ride home and uber
was you know it's like this milfy kind
of 45 year old lady 40 year old lady and
she was like oh were you just on I was
like I was performing she was like I
wanted to go to the show but I couldn't
and I said well here come tomorrow I got
her some tickets ended up banging the
uber drivers she just got divorced and I
said I'm staying she knew where I was
staying because she dropped me off and I
said when you get off come by and I'll
get you off and did you say that
something like that yeah some horrible
line I was in the car with a bunch of
the comics so I was like doing it in
front of them which was weird but then
we got to the hotel I told her what room
I was in and like four hours later I was
laying in bed I'd taken a sleeping pill
which is always a bummer and then I
heard a knock and that was it so I had
to fight through the pill and go at it
how'd it go it was great it was great
victory float very Florida a lot of
crazy tats a lot of anal stuff you name
it took a shower it was wild uber baby
it's the unn the untapped dating app I
guess uh yeah I mean it's a lot of
Middle Eastern men but if you can find a
blonde Florida mom I say go for it
Wow yeah it was a fun night you're an
inspiration to us all Marc I guess I got
a free ride after all five stars five
stars on the five stars it's an easy
joke we won't I know I don't want your
your lady to hear all this so we'll
pivot a little bit because we can't
comedy is also a mistress oh I like it
segue we call that in the biz yes egg
weight kids also a little vehicle and
when we're thinking of comedy being the
the devilís mistress she is I know you
had the Comedy Central special came out
yes but you want it to be are you
pitched it to Netflix first or Netflix
said no yes so what what was comedians
we're seeing a comedian like every day
get on Netflix oh yeah what is what is
even the process do you go to mountain
it Netflix and you're like here is
something I taped like what is that
whole process the
approach them and were they looking for
what happened basically I think you got
a just film something now it's all
different now before you can just send
them a tape of like here's here's 20
minutes of my hour it's killing I think
this could be something or I shot an
hour on HD 4k here you go tell me what
you think if you want to buy it and now
they're so they're so closed off now
because they realize that the biggest
they realize they've got they've got all
the exposure everybody wants you know
it's like Ellen Seinfeld Chapelle Rock
like they all go Netflix so they know
they have that power and now they don't
want to take a shot on some young guy
like before Segura was kind of like oh
we'll take you whatever Oh Tony
Hinchcliffe Ali Wong whatever and they
just accepted those and then boom they
blew up but now there's so many comics
that I don't think they want to just
take everything like I know some guys
I'm not gonna say their names put killer
killer comics Netflix won't even answer
their emails and everything and I'm like
now they just put it on YouTube and
they're killing and I'm like Netflix you
could have had that like comedy is all
about the up-and-coming hungry new guy
or girl
it's not about Ellen I get it Ellen will
bring tickets in and Sandler has a
special so they'll bring views but like
I don't know you got you got a book
because the guys on the road are the
ones who are good they're the ones like
in the pocket top of their game just
slugging out at a funny bone every
weekend you know you're getting yeah
what's his [ __ ] name like Seinfeld I
get it he's a legend and a draw and all
that but like I don't know the specials
are weird it's like let me show you my
old act and all that I'm like what good
there's a million guys murdering it with
new [ __ ] killing original and they can't
get a break is Netflix went to big they
went to big it's it's got to be like
Howie Mandel's coming out with one mono
Ray Romano you gotta be like this
legendary status which I get it gives
them a good brand like look at us we
have the elite on here which I get but
it put the new guys on as well but I
don't know I don't know but a business
perspective I mean it makes sense they
if it was gonna be like hey I'll do a
special on your network it's like okay
who we gonna pick right you know I mean
like totally of course and I get that
but Ray Romano you got to pay 20 million
gimme give me 200 grand I'm in baby and
it'll it'll help my career and uh also
I'm in this for the long haul
like I'm 35 I'll be doing this in 30
years you know I'm still gonna go but I
get it but here's the beauty of Netflix
turning down everybody it's caused all
these young great comics to do their own
thing go online start a podcast start a
web series you know the more rejection
you get ironically makes you stronger
and more versatile and and creative you
get outside the box and you start you
start putting out your own [ __ ] and
thank God for you too I mean they say
YouTube is gonna be the next thing when
Netflix goes away that's what I've been
fascinated with what Andrews Schultz's
that's one guy I was talking about yeah
when he was on here and we were talking
about like how he shopped his special
everywhere yeah nobody wanted it and it
seems funny he's got good stuff it's
hedgy as hell yeah
topical but he's you know also it's it's
the whole like you're another white guy
thing which nobody likes when you bring
that up but like there's a million white
guys and you kind of blend together
after a while so yeah so like a lot of
white guys are getting creative and I
get it I'm all about diversifying and
all that but like don't just put up a
guy because he's trans or whatever is to
me that feels weird like get off this
funny trans comics put them on they'll
just put them on because I feel like
that's offensive and a weird we just
want to check a box exactly exactly and
I get it they're trying to cover their
ass but like let's keep the quality up
there's final a ton of funny minorities
you know you don't need to put on a bad
one
so did you film your special yourself
and then you pitch the to Netflix no I
just you talk about the Comedy Central
one yes no they said no so Amy Schumer
said hey I'll produce it and Comedy
Central was like we'll take that they
wouldn't take it was just me did you
pitch them to see if there yeah they
were like sorry we like you but sorry
and I was
okay and then Schumer's like I'll put my
name on it and they're like we'll take
it in science again it's the business
you know so oh so you even have one
filmed yet no no you went to Netflix
like hey I have an hour but yes it
wasn't filmed or anything no nothing cuz
I've heard of comics doing it all
themselves and then they like presented
to Netflix I've heard that is it up but
I had at that was like 2016 I had no
money I couldn't afford to because those
are like 30 40 grand did you know how
much those kind of productions usually
cost it's it's not cheap you got to rent
the place you got to rent the equipment
you got to get a guy to edit it a color
corrector all that [ __ ] and it just
keeps going up and up and you know
they'll be like it'll be 50 grand by the
end of it at 72 grand you're like damn
then you get 100 grand back so you're
like alright I made 20 grand I guess but
then the agents take 10 percent so but
to me like that's why I might just go
Schultz's are out and go youtube because
I just want people to see it I just want
people to come out and buy tickets I
don't need to be [ __ ] Sebastian
Maniscalco that's not my goal I mean
he's on a another planet I just want to
be a comic that people care about so you
just need when it comes to YouTube I
guess you're not making money when you
pay on YouTube immediately but the money
comes on the road is how you means you
put yeah free labs have returned with
ticket sales exactly okay because once
you start selling out a it's there's so
many pronged effects that help your
career and I'm geeking out here this is
some real comedy [ __ ] the game but ok ok
in it all the way I promise that's what
my brain goes you're [ __ ] up you're
blowing it but I'm gay yeah no dude
you're this is perfect alright what we
need so hey you get your [ __ ] out there
so now people go okay you're this kind
of guy cuz I do a lot of late-night sets
and late-night sets are squeaky clean
they alter your material they say can
you change hobo to you know urban camper
or whatever the [ __ ] it is you're like
alright this is not really me anymore
but [ __ ] it I'd like to get on
television and get some views so that's
the whole thing but with your hour you
want it to be edgy you want to say
whatever you want you want it to be
completely you and I feel like some
place is kind of take
thattaway but where YouTube won't those
go yeah do whatever you want so now you
get people coming to see you and they
know you it's not one of those things
where they see you on Comedy Central
being squeaky clean then they come out
and see you they're like whoa that was a
lot of jokes on pedophilia you're like
well this is Who I am
I'm a pedophile but uh so uh you get the
people who you want to come see you and
now you got your own audience that knows
you so you can be weirder you can try
more and get creative instead of just
having like set up punch set up punch
that will work in any room you can kind
of be more you and branch out and figure
out who you are more because they know
you does that make sense yes
you know like go watch old bill burr you
watch old Gilbert he's like how you
doing folks good to be here he's wearing
a suit he looks weird his name wasn't
Billy now you watch Bernie's like what
the [ __ ] is up with this [ __ ] he's
talking about everything he wants to
talk about which he couldn't have done
before you need your crowd to do that so
that's one good thing about just putting
it out there and having people come see
you yeah and that's these problems
almost create progress like you were
saying in terms of oh they here's a
roadblock oh we'll just find another
route yeah and it's the more unique and
authentic route and isn't it terrifying
thinking about like the nine early 90s
when a guy like a killer act is they
were prizes out there in obscurity
killing and nobody knew about him and
then you you know on TV they show you
[ __ ] Elayne Boosler and Dennis
wolfburg and you're like yeah these are
funny but like what if this some
murderer out there that we never know
about because these gatekeepers just
won't let them in hmm now that is the
value of the Internet is you can create
yourself exactly yeah and that's what
people are doing and boy it's Jay I mean
look at Joe Rogan's podcast it's like
zillions of his some news and like
that's his on YouTube like mmm if you
went to Netflix who knows five years ago
whenever he started they would have been
like we're just gonna play you on a mic
what like you're not gonna buy that he'd
be like okay and then put on YouTube
eight million 10 million views that's
crazy
yeah cuz even thinking of the internet
verse television or YouTube verse like
the old tube did your Comedy Central
especially even get traction like no
nobody saw it it was almost like people
saw your late-night sets more than like
[ __ ] well you know it's a couple
reasons again I should tell you I ate an
edible like three nights ago and I'm
just so bur now so there's you're like
the first person I've talked to sober I
did at the set last night I was still a
little I can't mess with that stuff man
it's too worse the word don't ever do it
kids edibles who is really not worth it
not worth I'm just counting the minutes
shaking it was brutal so what was the
question so we're getting a fresh
Normand right here yeah this is fret so
I'm talking so when I got I got a lot to
get out no that's great no we were just
talking about your Comedy Central
special knock oh yeah nobody saw it I
put these clips online now on Instagram
those get way more hits than Comedy
Central because you can share it they're
small they're like a minute long and
that's the key now man like TV it's I
hate to say it but it's you know comes
on once if you miss it it's over whereas
online just lives forever and like
sometimes people see one video they're
like I like that and they'll go check
next three down like what else has he
done and they scrolling through and I'm
getting views on videos from like two
years ago and stuff so the Internet's
the way to go because that that late I
mean that Comedy Central nobody saw that
also Schulz set a good point where he
thinks people don't want to watch an
hour
you know everybody puts out their big
hour their big special but nobody can
get through a full hour so his thing is
he puts short clips on YouTube and
they'll watch one after another which
will actually spend two hours doing but
they'd like to be able to control it and
he broke his special up to like 15 he
did like 15 minutes at the cellar
probably like what Ray Romano did pretty
much after Schulz released his yeah I
don't know I mean I don't know if he
took the idea or not but Schulz he like
did a 15-minute set the cellar then
moved on to the next and the next and
kind of broke up his special to make it
more like a documentary right there's an
actual special yeah I remember that do
you think that that's for like I mean
like okay let's say for me for instance
okay I was wanting to shoot a special
would you say based on your experience
and the knowledge you have in the
industry would it be more savvy to do
like an unorthodox format as opposed to
me just coming out here I am for an hour
I would go
Orthodox all the way always an unknown
guy just go break through with something
weird and different because you put out
an hour pill gonna go who's this I don't
know what else you got Oh Brian Regan
all right you got to you got to stand
out a little bit
I think shake it up also he just Schultz
admits he's like I took this all from
music that's what they do that's how
they promote singles you know so he's
doing a single bit and I think it's it's
all very smart he's a smart he's a hell
of a marketer that guy
yeah very savvy yeah so I don't have an
ounce of that [ __ ] so uh I'm trying to
learn it cuz this is part of the
business now so would you almost think
for your special you'll do something
more unorthodox oh yeah yeah oh yeah I
filmed I did an album last week it went
great everything worked I filmed it on
4k with two different angles just to
have it cuz you never know but again
it's being a club it's not like a big
theater I'm wearing a t-shirt you know
it's a brick wall so who knows if anyone
will buy it but I might just put it up
on YouTube [ __ ] it yeah I might maybe I
mean I'll see if I can get some money
from it or like maybe I'll show it to
HBO like will you buy this or will you
let me do this hour and whatever I don't
know but they'll probably no one will
want it but I think I'm able to put on
YouTube but if somebody does buy it like
like let's say a Comedy Central when
we're talk about the business of like a
special mm-hmm do you just getting
upfront payment or do you get upfront
and then you may get a cut if it gets a
lot of traction as well you get an
upfront they're all upfront
especially Comedy Central they're very I
don't want to say they're strapped but
they're like we don't have we don't have
money just give gotcha so they'll put it
up once and maybe put a couple clips on
YouTube maybe and that's it yeah it's
very strange I don't get it either
I don't get it don't you want people to
see this as well you put it forward put
it out there right hey they got
everything at workaholics reruns to play
you know because that's really what
people watch like you know I heard on
Netflix the thing the two most watched
shows are the office and friends really
and they cost like a zillion dollars a
year to keep the rights to it but that
just keeps people on Netflix you know
that they watch hours
girl she sleeps to the office she puts
it on just goes to bed it's it's it's
part of our you know the American
culture now where it's just it's like in
the zeitgeist just that I'll be there
for you you know you just like I feel
familiar and you you you you go to bed
yes I think it's just a way to shut down
now that's familiarity okay
that's why everything on TV now is like
we're remaking Jumanji we're remaking
ghostbusters we're remaking yeah Starsky
and Hutch whatever the hell it is it's
like we want we're so up our own asses
that we have to have something that
we've heard of before so maybe the an
Orthodox special is looking at old old
specials and maybe just kind of
reinventing me reinventing it away
making it a derivative not stealing it's
a derivative right as they say in the
art world what a bad idea though hey
please yeah like it like a vintage kind
of thing yeah just see what cuz it's
kind of like how Andrew was saying you
know he adapted from music yeah their
format maybe just yeah maybe and instead
of us trying to figure out what's next
it's like well what happened and see if
we can just bring that to be next sure
it's not a bad idea just see what's out
there but now you're just recreating
again now you're just making another
remake yeah I guess but it's a remix but
it's a remix the who knows people I
don't know I mean someone's gonna be
like oh I'll do that but then you still
gotta do the work that's right for hey
that's what I love about this show is
like sometimes people are like oh I
don't want to give away too much I was
like people still have to do do it yeah
like nobody's doing anything
the idea is the easy part right I mean
how many friends you have go hey I'm
gonna write a screenplay you're like
great go do it
two years later like what happened
they're like ah things came up like just
don't tell me anything you're gonna do
unless you're doing it exactly that's
the new rule I don't even get excited
about anything until after it's done
right so like one of my goals this year
is to shoot a special so I feel like if
I say it out loud that's going to hold
me accountable if I keep saying it on
the record
ya know right because one you know the
special that you can then break up into
content like you said and get exposure
that way but also I've
heard like the spins from like satellite
radio oh yeah like money good money
the prices actually went up for spins
really so yeah it's it's a viable source
of income I know a lot of guys
especially clean material are you clean
yeah
oh dude just record a half-hour and send
it to them oh yeah they'll play the [ __ ]
out of because no one's clean now so
like they have all these people
listening to clean stations on Sirius
and it's like the same eight guys it's a
Nate bargatze it's Jim Gaffigan it's
Brian Regan over and over again so if
you get in there you're set because
they'll play the [ __ ] out of it oh yeah
this is some real inside jizz here folks
I love any any time you almost get to a
sentimentality you have to flip it I got
a full comedian brain jizz has to be
like well not quite no I don't want to
feel anything okay so you just you can
just record the I guess you don't need
video it's just you can send an audio
version of us if I if I did like a
feature set I could just send that in
send it in interesting I mean at least a
half-hour you want to give them oh okay
okay and you want to be quality you
won't be your best version don't want to
be like some half-baked joke out there
but serious is so cool cuz somebody will
hear that and [ __ ] portland and be
like hey you're really funny i showed my
friends you have an album do you have a
youtube yeah whatever and then you start
getting a little buzz going yes yeah
britain might hear it or scotland or
whatever that's I mean that's what I've
noticed with this podcast is we almost
have like there's almost like hot breath
hubs a little bit and like Montreal we
have like a nice little core
listenership we are in a England we have
I don't even know what the call I leave
it as Inglot Britain's the old name yeah
a little a little pretentious
I don't know went Liberal Arts I don't
know angry yeah England and then Ireland
there's a few like it's it's it's
amazing when the internet like how you
can connect with people oh yeah just I'm
sure cuz you you not only have created a
bunch of comedy content but even like
the podcasts like it's you have your
nice own ecosystem have you seen that to
be driving ticket sales yeah for sure
cuz I'm no nowhere near a big draw
but like I got a podcast people are
enjoying it so I'll get like 10 to 15
fans at every show now which is great
because you already at the walk-up
traffic you get the we need something to
do tonight traffic and then you fill
that in with your people they fill in
those little pockets so now you got a
sellout with some of your fans and your
fans are dying and they're going crazy
so the other people go maybe we should
go crazy and it just it like infects the
whole crowd in a good way
yeah so just having so I can't imagine
my head like a full room of fans that
would be very exciting like when you
open for like a cry sure or a Rogen or a
cigar or whatever these people have
their own peep that every single seat is
a fan who knows them and loves them I
would get nothing done you could just
come out and go hey I'm a douche and
they'd be like you know no I Steve
Martin quit I guess it is yeah like it
was just like layups at some point it's
just too crazy yeah I remember here's a
fun story
well I when I open for Louie years ago
he would always be like man I would kill
be where you are like just running
around Brooklyn earning laughs cuz he
gets a lot of laughs based on being
Louie you know so he's like I would kill
to get that genuine response again just
to know if it's actually funny killed me
where you are cut to two years later he
gets popped and I text him I was like
hey welcome back to my level
and he never wrote back so I think he
was a the guy went too far there but it
was still raw I should have given it in
like a month but now okay see now the
the comedian and me wanting to worry
about networking may not try to push
that envelope and made I may like not
want to do that thinking of it I don't
want to ruffle any feathers but in your
career do you just you're just like
whatever this is what I think you don't
want to do what so it's like if I'd open
for Louie before okay he just had this
event come out yes he got popped like
you said and then I like and then I
don't know if I would want to text him
hey and back down with me oh yes is if
like well then maybe I won't be able to
open for him again or me ain't me you're
like well is that just all just delusion
that no not worry about I think you're
smarter than me because I didn't even
think about that I was like this'll be
funny a joke right she's doing a joke
and he's a comic and we know each other
so at
it'll be fun but I think it was such a
devastating blow that I think it was
like all right I don't have time for
this [ __ ] right now so but also I can't
say how many countless times that's hurt
me just saying here's a joke I haven't
thought about yet or haven't thought
about the consequences and I just say it
and sometimes it helps and a lot of
times it hurts so keep doing what you're
doing okay don't just say [ __ ] cuz uh I
got beat up and I've gotten fired and
all that so like yeah you gotta watch
what you say but I am missing that
little guy on the shoulder going I
wouldn't do that one okay well it's just
was comedians listening to this and like
even me we like look at someone like you
and they're like oh yeah he did it he's
done it like I'm done but I was a lot of
fuck-ups over the along the way but so
it's almost just you being funny almost
kind of will sweep those under the rug
eventually is that yeah yeah funny is is
should be number one it's like ninth on
the list now of why people get big but I
think at the end of the day if you
really look back funny is what wins
there's a zillion comics I started with
who were like had a lot of heat and they
were blowing up and they were getting
stuff and they just never wrote and kind
of fluffed off and now they're gone and
I've only been doing it 12 ish years so
imagine a 20 year career you see a lot
of people come and go yeah you think
like Bert Kreischer it took him like 20
years to hit yeah and that was the
internet you know yeah this book and now
he's huge he put that clip on Facebook
and then boom I know and he'd been doing
it forever and he's had like four shows
like people don't realize what you got
to do just to get Tosh once said you'll
never realize how famous you aren't you
know because there's always somebody who
doesn't know you you know like he's on a
sitcom he does arenas he's got huge
specials and there's some people like
who Daniel Tosh you're like yeah that's
that's how it goes
oh yeah you know your mom doesn't know
bilborough's does she I don't know what
she knows well she's a little kooky but
yeah did you have sex with her too is
that when but your mom possibly I just
figured you've probably had an awkward
run-ins like that before
oh yeah many weird run-ins
but yeah yeah you know comics I forget
you know act like this is the center of
the universe but it's it's just like a
niche art form that three people care
about yeah it is but as comedians it's
everything it's everything
yeah but we're basically like in a punk
band pontificating on like did you see
rat dick what a band oh they they they
were pure or they had integrity and you
know these other guys are you know
sucking the man's dick they're corporate
now and you're like nobody gives a [ __ ]
wait we got problems we got kids we got
a hobby yeah but that's what I do with
comedy and I got to realize hey this is
just like this weird subset of of
entertainment that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about so as comedians coming up what are
what are some tips you can have as we
land this plane here cuz this is you
know it's all about just comedy in the
comedy game and what what are some tips
you could maybe share with comics ooh
some big tips all right cut down on the
booze don't go too hard I was uh here's
the problem with booze do you drink
not really good good for you but uh just
I love it so much and I want a party I
want to get drunk but it kills your
whole next day and I have bad anxiety so
when I'm hungover my anxiety goes
through the roof and I'm like you suck
you're gonna bomb this joke isn't good
you're trying to write you're like it
all stinks have you ever written a joke
in your life you kill yourself you suck
okay so all that [ __ ] and all that comes
out and I already have enough of that
sober so when I'm drinking it's it's
even worse but uh so cut back on the
booze just right right right even you
got nothing in your head just go back to
old tweets look at old jokes try
something on a stage if you're doing a
new bit and you're kind of not doing
well with it just throw in three more
sentences real quick like what else
always stretch as much as you can don't
go out and bomb a ton but like what last
night I went onstage I was like I'm
gonna riff about Atlanta a little bit
maybe nothing will come maybe it'll be
humiliating but it's not the end of the
world so even when you're like alright
pull out pull out do three more
sentences just say [ __ ] it it's almost
like when you're doing reps and you're
on that last one and you can't do it but
you want to give up your friend go just
push it a little bit even if you just
get it up to here instead of not doing
it just
we'll give you some muscle I think it's
the same with comedy just push it a
little further just stretch it as much
as you can until you feel them like all
right all right we got it
and if you do that enough over years
you'll become amazing because you you a
you're building something B you're
learning what it feels like to be
frazzled and and push that down you know
that feeling of panic when you're on
stage or like this is bombing abort keep
going and push your abort button further
away you know so you can build that that
Callos of like I can take a little bit
of bombing I can take it because I'm
such a wuss like people go you got so
many punchlines I'm like yeah I'm scared
of silence I'm not this brilliant writer
guy I'm just I'm punching it up so I
don't have to feel anything so yeah I
always push it a little further try to
riff do that joke that you're scared of
doing sometimes when I'm on stage I'm
like a little nervous out of my element
I'm like this isn't going as well as I
hoped that's when you try the new bit
because that's when you're the most
vulnerable and raw and it'll actually
kick you into being yourself it's almost
like when you're trying to when you're
with a girl and you're trying to be cool
and funny and it's not going that great
just go well this isn't going that great
hold on let me let me reboot here it
just it's the it's the thing your brain
is telling you don't do do that
sometimes go towards that [ __ ] it's like
the del closed thing follow the fear go
towards the fear sometime and everything
in your brain say don't but that's when
you should and it makes the fear go away
ironically go into it lean into the skid
it's like that bill birthing he's like
when you're doing stand-up if you're bad
at going to crowd work
go to crowd work cuz you've got to learn
it and the only way to learn is to dive
in it's like basketball players I can't
go left well then work on going left the
same thing so this is all you know heavy
inside baseball Anil but just you know
try it it's right it's right down though
you know you got that weird Joker like
this is weird
try it let's go what's gonna happen this
is all prey that's the cool about
stand-up it's all batting practice until
TV or the special obviously you don't
want to use the audience too much and
just be like
you guys are my canvas I'm gonna take a
[ __ ] on you and whatever works I'll keep
it cuz then you'll be a bad comic so
play walk that line of being a pro
killing giving them a good show and
working out your [ __ ] and trying [ __ ]
and that's a that's a good line and I
think some people respect it they want
to hear the new [ __ ] they want to hear
you working it out so yeah that's my tid
bit
this is tidbit good stuff man hey thing
I feel like I'm finally coming out of
this edible eye that when I asked about
comedy tips you liked you came to life
wow this is all I have no but it's fun
like we can just talk about comedy as if
it's our first day still yes fresh you
know I love it it's a special thing and
people are trying to ruin it and it
sucks but push on through baby push on
through baby be yourself and you know go
gay go I knew I knew there was something
right around the corner hey you guys
running out well hot breath averse
that's gonna be it for us thank you guys
for hanging out if you did enjoy this
please all we ask here just share it
just let another comic know up in
conversation and an open mic or you're
out at a club just tell other comics
about it share a clip on Facebook
whatever you got to do just to spread
the comedy mastery we're doing here at
hot breath we have mark Normand a one of
the the masters of this craft learning
masters in practice only 12 years in and
the success he's already found it's only
gonna grow exponentially from here so
just push towards the fear yeah there
you go
which I should take my own advice
sometimes and push that internet button
that says subscribe and also really our
website go to hot breath podcast calm
that's we're gonna get our blog and all
our other sorts of fun info on there but
all that being said mark Norman's thanks
be on humpr hey thanks for having me and
praise Allah there he is all right
[Music]
you